僕は今は修女2年生主体学院の2年生です
そのまで6年間グラフィックデザインを勉強してきました
なのに何で僕が自転車でかまどが起こるのかそういう話をしたいと思います
まずこのたぞご覧ください
どちらの写真が好きですか
どっちを出しません
どっちも好きかな僕はね指輪ね好きだっていうね
なんか楽しそうに見えデザインいてとは黒だと思ってて
なんか楽しくすることを面白くすること例えば僕はグラフィックでないとしてポスター
を作ったりお菓子のパッケージをつくったりすることをしているんですけどその時に
いつも考えるとって基本的には同じで
どうやったらこの商品がもっと魅力的に見えるだろうもっとかっこよく見えるんだろう
ということを考えています
デザインとほとんど楽しいことだと僕
と思います
思い立ったが吉日これ僕の座右の銘です今日はこういう話をしたいと思いますもう
ちょっと
具体的にするとアイディアを思いついたならそれは行動に移すべき
そういう話をしたいと思います
こんなステージに乗っています
後ろ祈っていうのがかまどですね浜撮って終わりましたね
昔のご飯を炊く機械痛い
なんでこんなものによっているのか理由は3年前にさかのぼります
まあ
3年前ですねつくば市のはい皆に戻りそれがいますたスーパーという指定車屋さんで
こんなシチュエーションを見ました
スプーンちょっと面白いです今な量の荷物乗っけてる自転車があってもう
期からキャップもて話なんですねそしたら彼のオーナー福田さんは富豪面白くて
地点射程外どうも知らんじゃなくて生活の一部なんだよ
だからどんなにモスの子供を乗せてとかに遊びに行きたいんだという話をしてください
ました
僕たち筑波大生低
違う
人ぐらい1万1000円以上が定額の7割以上の人が毎日のマーシャルとか
まあとにかく自転車に乗ってるんですけどでも基本的には家と学校の往復をするための
道具だと僕は思ってたんですねでもこの話を聞いてすごい
知念背負って面白いなって思ったですもう一つ蔵さんを半焼してくれました
彼が2011年東日本大震災当然に東京の自転車さんに勤めていたときそこの在庫の
自転車が全部売り切れだという話です
結構創造には難しくないと思うんですけど公共交通機関が止まって車が動かなくて渋滞
になって丸い家に帰るわけにもいかないからみんな自転車を買って帰ったらしいです
その時にちょっと話してなんか
悲しいなと僕は思ったんですけど
ただ自転車をごそれこそ移動の手段を持っているんじゃなくてでも買ってた人はみんな
凄い腰自分で買ってきたっていう話をしてて
だいたいロードバイクだって自分マン少なくても10万円する充満するものをみんなが
実は欲しかったんだよねって言ってその当時に買っていって全て売り切れたそうですが
この話を聞いたときに自分に
やらなきゃと思ったんで
で自分たちがやっているか丸プロジェクトでも自転車じゃないができないかなって考え
ました
ここでかマゾと自転車こっくぢるわけですね加茂のプロジェクト神勇
かまどってこういう字を書きます
筑波山の友と豊穣という地区の
近くにですね古民家を借りていてそこの
伝統的なかまだを
これをですね使えるようにもう1回再生式あってそれでご飯を炊いてみんなでの会社会
を開くとか
レンガでかまど自体を作ったりピザ窯を作ったり
個人的にはですねもう土と石と花と水を混ぜてかまど自体
作るみたいなこともやっていますその次に僕たちは自転車で
かまどハほぼ思いました
雷終了でますライスと葉萎縮を合わせたぞですこういう思っています後ろに
けど8ですねー
作ったからには動かさなきゃいけないと
思ったので
いろんな場所に出店しに行きました人たちなんか勇気し色んな場所でこういうこの子
停車に乗ってそこまで行ってそこでご飯を炊いて
そういうことをやっています
こんなことになりました宝篋山って言って
筑波山の隣にありちょっと低いやがったんですけども連覇となところまで自転車で
行けるんですよ
だから自転車で行ってみようかといって
山頂でご飯を炊いてみたいしました
山の頂頂ますこれを交えたからさ
これ面白くないと言われたじゃあやるかって言ったんですけど僕たち
この時に走りとかお皿を持ってくの忘れてこちらですね端数の2期から端数箱をとって
それで52位を作って食べたりとかしました
魂のプロジェクト大事にしていることが3つありますまず楽しいこと
楽しくないと僕たちも痛くないしそれを見たいと思ったも楽しく音が楽しいと人が
集まります
人が集まり僕私はそれをコミュニティをつくるデザインだと思っています
人が集まって雛分同じ釜の飯
みんなでターゲット他人がもう他人じゃなくなる友達になる瞬間
そういうものを作っています
この活動自体を始めた理由というものがあります6年前
2011年3月11日北は宮城県の出身です
当時高校3年生でした卒業式が終わって
さんが11日も
特にあることがなかった後は大学院に行こう大学では僕は筑波大学で
デザインのグラフィックデザイナーで今日しようと思っていました
その時に地震がありました
同時
高速道路教師
自動車免許を取るため高速道路教習でそれが終わったところの eca 超絶ところで
地震がありました
あの木はキュッという緊急地震速報が僕たちを初めて聞いたんですけど何が起きたか
わかるんですよ
僕は運転してるしなんかは日本とした方とか思ってたら
地震が来て周りのカラスが全部俺て
電線が切れて信号が灯りました信号が止まった
けどブーベロサティ
くれと言われて
ここまできましたこれ投じたが省のジャスコって言われたんですけどまぁ4
ショッピングセンターの屋上までに得ました
ました
ものをするぐらいで
気が上がってきて海がすごく効いているのが見えました
10分20分ぐらい僕たちは上からずっと下の重体になっている車に向かって早く
逃げろって叫ぶ
暮らしができなかったんですけどその後この3階の天井まで
運命でありました
これは20001年3月11日の次はに12日から3週間
僕は威厳を取って
た習慣や意見に作られていくのが良いたんですけどその間に聞かせ水道たとに全部ない
状態でした
今まで毎朝給水車水を汲みに行って帰って来て周りの近所に4世代の方たちと一緒に
朝晩
代表する水塩してね集まってご飯食べる
7厘とかインターンを使って外で
あったんですね電気もガスもないか
この時にすごく僕が思ったことがあって今から僕はグラフィックデザインを大学に行っ
て勉強しようと思ってたと聞いても
こういう災害の時って全然デザインや来たためちゃったと思ったんですね
むしろ掲示板とかに貼ってあるのって他の歯さんが描きで買えるものなんですけど
その災害のときはそれがすごい後ろ暖かく感じるというか安心できる
もしそれが他の綺麗な
デザインになってプリント間されたものだったら
なんかすごいそぐわない冷たい感じがするなーと思って
でも
そういうふうにまだこれから勉強しようと思っているものを
現実的に突きつけられてどうしたらいいんだをちょっと思ったんですね
思いまー実際こと言うとデザインでポスターだけじゃなくてパッケージだけじゃなくて
もっとそれだけじゃない
グラフィックデザインというのは確かに大事それはデザインだと思われていくと
コミュニティをでさえているも僕はデザインだと思っています
人が集まり方法を作ること集まる場所を創ることそれでもデザインだと思っています
両方
必要なこと
僕はこの震災で学んだことがあります
アイディア思いついたからそれは構造に移すべきだ
なぜならもし災害の時にですよ
何かあなたがアイディアを持っていたらそれを行動にずつ
べきだ映さなかったらもしかしたら何かの命がなくなるかもしれない
逆に言うともしあなたの報道を映した方への命が救われるかもしれない
これは僕は災害だけじゃなくそう思っています
だからかまどプロジェクトいうのは2013年から始めました
もともと使われなかったけどもう1回
煙突を掃除して使えるようにしてやって
そこでコミュニティをつくること
集まれる場所をつくることそういうことをお願いしています
なんで僕がこれを始めたのかもうありますよね
3週間ずっと毎日外で
近隣住民がちょっと集まって数字をしてたんですけどすごく大変なんですよ
もしこれが今使えてたらすごく楽だったと思うんです
だからそれをまだあるところではそれを支えるようにしてやるレンガでも綺麗にして
やる家でも作っているということが大事だと思っていますして公表しました
支援者サティも
本できるようになって
そこの場所で今から卵を作ってくださいというのは災害が起きた時には難しいけど自転
車だったらそこまで僕たちはいける
だからこういうことをやっています
いろんなタイプがありますトレーラーにつけるもの後ろに依頼をつけるの
こういうのも考えて作っているんですけどもっとよくできないかなぁと思って調べてい
ました
ここのサイトに行き着きました
ギザ3位リーフトライアス
これなんですけど
これ感覚えのレースの店しかも災害時を想定したか鴎外のレースというものをやってい
てもうこのビジョンがすごくいいいいなあと思ったんです
再会時給への手段として母をバイクの有用性快適性を証明する証明するです
そして
二つ目が最も災害時に適した彼は5倍の性能と技術を発展を目指すこともう
これは全く毎週と同じだと思うんですねだから僕たちはいこうってくれました
アイディアを持っているから
それをどうにか
行動にすること
本当にそれを僕たちはこの自分たちのやっていることを
膝スターリングとられずの人たちにも伝えたいし
ザファーリリーストライアルをやっている方家の思想とかも
どうやってこのカーボバイクを作っているんだろういうことも価値は知りたいと思って
これに参加することにしました
ただ問題が
場所がアメリカ合衆国俺はポートランドめちゃめちゃといいですね
かつお金がない僕はもちろん学生なんでだから大学にプレゼンしました
プレゼンしてそういう海外の研修医たちの助成金があって
そこでを
お金もらってアメリカに僭越僕たちは行ってきました
映像ですうわーっ
me
32海外事情想定した霊石いうと少しくらいような広島も知れませんでも彼らが一番
大事にしているのは楽しいと
7少なかったらリースでたくないよねっていう話で僕たち
これ買うバイクの頭の部分なんですけどここに水食糧
なまたまもたまたまボっていうのは療養費
守って守ってくれています
あとですね建築しないでこういうのも誇るんですよ
水自体は実際にこうやって買おうと楽んですけど
一つも食べタンク
このようにに住居になりますそれを6つ
運びます
もちろん携帯は使えないという設定なので上野間コートされます
それで11か所いろんなところで売って
入ってくるんですね
基本的にもこれって乗っかってるだけ
全然も運べないよどっちかって言うとっていう状態なんですけどでも災害時そんなこと
言ってられないよねっていうレースなんですねから夢ての駆け下りとか
これ最後のシーンなんですけど1メートルの壁を越えると家庭もあるんです
もし居るた方を横黙ってたら車もそれ以上いけないけど
自転車だったら超えられるように言っていい
そういうことを
行ってきました
disaster relief とは8時これはポートランドで2012年から
始まったものです
それが今はシアトルサンフランシスコいうジエンドといろんなところで同じ河本に開催
されています僕たちはこれを
つくばでもやりたいなと考えてい
その次の駅 the star リフトラージョの次の日に僕たちは自分がやっている
ことも彼らに伝えたいってから
ライスクッカーられるというもの
開催しました15人の方が来てくれます
何で僕が自転車でかまどを運ぶのか
そう言って抽象的に薬をみんなで火を書こう6
ため
ことでいいのかなと思いますコミュニティをつくることを面白いもの
人を集めてみんなで火を囲んで同じ釜のメシ6
それがコミュ1
僕は2つの
デザイン話を強調しましたグラフィックデザインとコミュニティデザイン
これってほとんど自転車偉大だと思うんですね
どっちかがなくてもダメだし両方なくちゃいけない
はアイディアを思いついたならそれは行動に移すべきだと思う
これは災害のときだけじゃなくて
いつでもだと思うんですね
いつでももしあなたが愛を持ってたらそれを向上に打つそそうするともっと社会全体が
楽しくなるんじゃないかなと思います
ああああああ